je reçois maintenant julie snyder une
productrice animatrice j'étais très
proche de rené angélil de céline dion
oui alors on voit tout ce qu'il a
apporté au showbiz québécois québécois
mais avouent qu'ils avaient travaillé
avec lui pendant plus de 20 ans oui ce
qui vous importe il m'a apporté parce
que je ne produisait pas mes émissions
de télé puis je travaille à radio canada
on avait fait 1-1 spéciale pour les
boues dimanche elle devait être un huit
minutes qui avait terminé en spéciale
pour les boues dimanche les mairies dit
j'aimerais ça qu'on travaille ensemble
parce que toi tu veux autant moins dé
foot veut plus et les j'avais dis moi
j'aimerais ça être productrice mais je
trouve ça difficile parce que je n'avais
pas de femmes conductrices animatrice à
l'époque je vois tu es mais moi j'en
parlais avec céline et la première
émission spéciale quand j'étais à tva
qui a eu sur céline et si toi tu vas
produits qui vous faisait confiant et il
m'a donné il m'a permis d'être devenir
productrice et je dis est ce que je vois
comment on va partager sur les 50 50
sociale et mayadine s'il démarre et pour
l'autre pour rappel ce soit rapide de ce
rappel toi de sault toute ta vie
si le deal est mauvais pour l'eau il est
mort est pour toi ça vaut en amour ça
vaut en affaires ça vaut dans n'importe
quoi tu vas faire donc il vous a
beaucoup appris énormément
il me donnait toute sorte de leçon de
vie toutes sortes d'enseignement et on
parle de sa vision c'est un visionnaire
comme même si lyn et c'est bien
évidemment dans les dernières années et
céline est devenu meilleur que moi c'est
elle maintenant qui me conseille mais je
brasse qui se nourrissait palais et se
nourrissait beaucoup leurs ambitions et
leurs visions et des fois il se chicaner
sur des photos moi je t'ai comprise
entre les deux je ne mets pas ça ils
étaient très amoureux
il souhaite toujours que céline était
très belle très sexy tous mais il
pourrait comme par exemple la chanson du
titanic céline ne voulait pas la chanter
c'est pour ça qu'elle un petit vibrato
le sharlto copley mais parce que le prix
un cappuccino avant de normalement
prendre fin puisque elle pousse chez
nous avant de chanter mais ils y
croyaient pas elle y croyait pour cette
chanson là elle
c'est lui qui le poussaient des fois
c'était elle qui le poussait et il était
extraordinaire parce qu'ils nous
disaient encore moi des fois je les
écoute redéposer me dire ça ils nous
disaient encore à et aurait dû voir
ailleurs comment chanter bien vu encore
nous convaincre qu'un chantait bien si
tu avais été loyal c'était quand à
chanter à 7 des notes il était encore
émerveillée par yann après toutes ces
années moi ça me fascinait a été mais il
a été fasciné dès le premier dès les
premiers moments vu au début ses amis
ses amis ses 32 go et trouve un peu fou
là il était en dépression de tout mettre
sur une petite fille de même leur
c'était en dépression de croire mais moi
le cas d'accord si céline sujet
l'interview est comme ça mais je faisais
sont un peu capoté jeudi qui vont
chanter avec barbra streisand du michael
jackson sont heureux si jamais vous ne
jamais vu ça mais nous on fait croire
qu'on pouvait réussir
puis non seulement offert ici mais
évidemment c'est l'énergie c'est celle
de la femme qui a vendu le plus de
disques de l'histoire de la musique
mais lui c'est un manager est pas
reconnue ya marqué pas juste le québec
l'oniam marqué le show-business de façon
magistrale et internationalement le yoyo
un gérant d'artistes qu'on connaît
partout dans le monde ce qui est rare si
c'est rarissime la nommez moi un gérant
d'artistes grandes stars féminines on
n'est pas capable dans nos médias on
nomme le colonel parker la différence
ans et qu on l aime pas qu il s'occupait
d'elvis presley et rené c'est que
rennais rené aimé son artiste n'était
pas une relation d'affaires c'est une
relation d'affaires au début qui est
devenue une relation d'amour et la
combinaison ça c'est ça a été explosif
il y avait un sens de l'humour avec ses
amis de gauche me rappelle que pierre
lacroix s'était déguisée en infirmière
lorsqu'il a vu son premier camp ça alors
pierre lacroix qui est assez corpulent
qui dirige l avalanche du colorado il se
mettait en infirmière à l'hôpital c'est
quelqu'un qui avait beaucoup rire aussi
et puis qui aimez l'asie beaucoup
beaucoup la vie week-end mais alors
comment on dit au revoir à quelqu'un
comme ça qui a été son mentor et qui
avec qui on a
on a travaillé aussi longtemps il disait
tout le temps parce que moi je t'ai
toujours nerveuse le plein de choses qui
disait tout le temps je lis tout va être
correct il finissait souvent souvent
quand je disais ouais j'suis pas sûr que
ça n'a pas fonctionné
tout doit être correcte alors c'est
drôle que vous posez cette question là
je m'étais pas posé ça mais je me dis
tout doux et de corée et on pense à lui
on pense à lui
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup julie
merci